I'm telling you dummy The Inquisitor is
Ezra Miller
that's a theory I can get behind
that makes way more sense that The
Inquisitor is Ezra Bridger it's not Ezra
it's obviously Barris it's not and I
don't know why you Champion for Qui-Gon
Jinn
listen like guys we gotta do the little
we're gonna watch Soca episode three
today people so use the force to leave a
like I guess follow MJ Tesla Star Wars
nerd on Instagram if you want but guys
I'm also on X hey I'm trying to
transition
to our sponsor greetings fellow questers
prepare to embark on a magical journey
with Omni Heroes the ultimate blend of
heroic fantasy and strategy RPG Envision
a world where Valkyries our Beacon of
light aren't snared by treacherous
demons your quest should you choose to
accept it morph into a nominee Guardian
Unleash Your Inner hero and save those
ethereal maidens from the clutches of
darkness two of our legendary lasses
stealing the spotlight dorabella with
spell so cool they're downright
enchanting Andy lular who's more than
just Athena's Shadow she's a blazing
Legend but wait there's more lore in
store how many Heroes isn't just about
brandishing swords and fleeing spells it
boasts a Synergy system remix over 100
Heroes to devise unbeatable team combos
conquer Realms and reign supreme and
adrenaline pack PVE and PVP battles
weave your strategies Flex those magical
muscles and Ascend the global Throne
weary from your request fret not Embrace
The Game's Idol charms or with a mere
wizardly wave or tap because you know
phone Watcher power soar from joining
Mystic guilts and navigating enchanting
labyrinths and trying your luck in
blackjack challenges that's a roller
coaster of runes and riches radio
Summers magic download and install Omni
Heroes now for a whoppy 777 free summons
secure minimum of five Legendary Heroes
ensuring an epic start Omni Heroes is
now available on both the Apple App
Store and Google Play Store and has
earned recommendations from Google Play
chillax or strategize with enchanting
Valkyries so brave adventurers are you
game leave it on me Heroes whatever we
spell slash and Synergy counts
fret full-length Reaction watch along
where you sync it with your own copy it
was so good available for super section
we took at our favorite sport to really
watch the episode
oh oh the Sabers now
was that Rex
I'd kill for Live Action wrecks I think
we'll get him in this show if it's gonna
happen it has to happen here
it's like that Demon Slayer episode
oh sweet all the different lightsaber
forms
this is exciting
oh oh
it's like training if I Grievous
oh no
I'm not certain lady Ren is ready for
that technique
shut up huying your skill with a weapon
comes from your Mandalorian upbringing
those skills alone will not be enough to
defeat our enemy Kane also helped
learning to wield the force takes a
deeper commitment
Force sensitive by the end of this and
I'm going to be like hot everyone who
gave me crap about it here
this on we're gonna do the classic
you're nothing but potential kid you're
joking you've literally seen Ezra do
this before you've got this
uh sick old Jedi symbol
I want you to see with more than just
your eyes feel the road Ricky Bobby do
you know where I am
next to who Yang are you sure
how'd she project her voice like that
Juilliard she can throw her voice
it's a lot of drama school taken all
that is around you
I love the mood of this I love my voice
oh Yang's falling asleep
[Music]
I love this
and the sound design to the surround
classic martial arts movie we're gonna
say it's tefloni's favorite
even the sword designs are just
wonderful I feel like Kendo swords
right
got one
oh very good Sabine
very bad to me don't let your rage get
ahead of you
use the foals she can't she never will
Michael
because she chooses not to oh she sensed
it
sweep the lake anger and frustration are
quick to give power yeah but they also
imbalance you
I'm not a balance you're on balance this
is a good throwback to tales of the Jedi
when Anakin was teaching Ahsoka how to
handle it
really good call yeah or it's just a
classic trope
eight wings
also we totally missed home one
oh one there it is
the chancellor she's waiting oh
yes has she aged you look well how's
young Jason oh Jason finally got
mentioned in fact he's on board
somewhere oh he's there somewhere
trouble with chopper have you thought
about Kaden at all I was attacked by
Imperial loyalists still working for
Morgan ellisbeth outliers
former Imperials working throughout
every level of the new republic
government have all taken an oath of
loyalty except those ones long live the
Empire doesn't sound like the kind of
loyalty we're looking for
but I believe their activity speaks to a
larger operation
involving thrawn thrawn
isn't this just another attempt to gain
New Republic resources to Aid in what
has ultimately been your personal quest
to find Ezra Bridger is there something
wrong with that were you ever in the war
senator
no just sat back and waited to see who
came out on top
[Music]
are you a [__] senator
where those balls that I do the Imperial
Fleet is scattered and broken they have
no centralized command unless
I've seen the Mandalorian Famous Last
Words thrawn is not your typical
Imperial officer
no he's not I know because I fought
against him
he's nuanced some people argue that he's
a good guy
bran Admiral
for a friend Ezra Bridger heroically
died with him you don't know that
he's getting a rise out of her I will
say they've done a great job at making
me happy that Starkiller base blew up
the new Republic with all of her
interactions with their government so
far
Jason oh he's less colorful he's gonna
be a Jedi he definitely got the human
genes it's okay his hair is a little
green I want to be a Jedi
he said he wants to be a Jedi the music
oh he definitely wants to be more like
his dad I was hoping that the urgency of
our situation could expedite my training
a bit you don't get like a certificate
Sabine you're not Luke Skywalker traffic
school I can't use a force I don't
feel it not like you do
sake bomb Force resides in all living
things even you so this is a you problem
if that's true then why doesn't everyone
use it
Talent is a factor
and mediclaureates
training and focus are what truly
defines someone's success amen sister
yes
start small
I want to be able to not lean for my
drink I'm going to give this my best
why did she decide to train her though
you know like what was it about her that
she was like I'm going to try I want to
know that specifically what went down
there I hope that we go back a little
bit but I feel like part of it's a debt
to both Kanan and Ezra you both knew
this wouldn't be easy
well what you said didn't help
Jedi Order would not have accepted her
she is not an acceptable candidate I
only speak the truth standards which
were proven over a millennia
and failed yeah times have changed I
don't need Sabine to be a Jedi
I need her to be herself
you do come from a long line of
non-traditional Jedi
that way she fits right in Yoda to Count
Dooku Count Dooku to Qui-Gon Qui-Gon to
Obi-Wan Obi-Wan Anakin Anakin to Ahsoka
and Ahsoka does it mean
very impressive Michael I'm very proud
of you well done I can name all the
presidents too
it's a little nudge
you can't force the force
[Music]
she could she did that Sabine did that I
heard you telepathically you win this
round
watch it moved by itself it walks away
I won't be joining you for this one and
neither will the fleet
what that's Bull fleet
era
the Yang what's happened she was better
at politics all cotton Transmissions are
being jammed oh someone's undertale
space so far from the planet standard
Jedi Mission protocol When approaching
an unknown situation we park down the
street whatever it is has a signature
which is unknown to me
so much unknown stuff in this not for a
long what do we got here
oh man this look like bad guys
the Squadron of World War II fighter
pilot as well it kind of remind me of
like uh
on it
nice oh we're getting New Hope
references I feel it
so you got rid of my presets
[Music]
two and three close range and engage can
never understand why like high value
Forest wielding individuals would risk
flying in ships
again remember
learn to anticipate now's not the time
for a lesson yeah it's always a time for
a lesson oh yeah
come on Sabine just get one I have
several thoughts on everything else okay
not now the way you're those actions
I love that look that she gave who Yang
was right
get into the zone
I love it
all right ready
I love the processing of emotions that
you could feel on Rosario Dawson's
I love you now just get one
all right let's go let's go
do a barrel roll
I have two more incoming
I love how this is just becoming a
full-on training session
get one come on yeah
[Music]
yeah
let's roll them copy that her tendrils
have so much movement they did such a
good job
they shouldn't stare at somebody's
tendrils
they called leku
there's a well-crafted sequence
oh boy
yeah it's like a hyperspace Drive yeah
just some sort of hyperspace ring I'd
like to confirm
excellent
Morgan are you gonna fly into it prepare
turbo lasers
turbo base
well if you play empire
thanks for talking over it it's a kylo
ren mask if you're not going to hear
they're real there's an obvious clue
that it was Ezra
he literally said I Ezra Bridger agreed
to the plan
I got Green Lasers
Dre uses sound design
[Laughter]
this is beautiful I'm excited to get
this track in Star Tours coming up
[Music]
I'm excellent piloting
yeah
so cantankerous
Don't Look So Satisfied yeah she seems
so happy
foreign
destroyed nice Cut
series over
and we will have a three episode in
memoriam
oh it's an unsettling shot
get on it gotta put on your own oxygen
mask first
[__]
um
we'll take it from here
I like this little rivalry it's an
uneasy Alliance
out there out there just keep working
any fighter I'm gonna pull a layer yeah
just Mary Poppins that [__]
she is a captivating performer she does
a lot with a little I think the villains
this is the best villains we've had oh
my God yes whoa okay yes
this is what I'm talking about let's go
especially than a helmet especially
super perfect
[Music]
oh my God
[Applause]
this is really cool that's really
inventive
did you fix the ship yet
it's awesome awesome shots
Jeepers
wow that was really well orchestrated
nice trick
oh my god get me a Funko figure of this
oh it's happening on good time
this is a genuinely exciting aerial
sequence yeah feels like a good cross
between Star Wars and like an actual
World War II kind of thing I mean that's
how we made all the original scenes
[Music]
oh my God damn
oh [__]
she has her on top of it
[Music]
and Paula tradies online
oh the scope and scale of them oh I'm
loving the perspective it's
extraordinary
geez go in the mouse ever seen Pinocchio
monster all this [__]
oh hell yeah hey Cthulhu
it could be Starkiller
again those locked off shots
[Music]
this is a [__] blast I mean how do
you make a unique new type of Star Wars
space Chase sequence
where
[Music]
are they
complete
we almost died multiple times oh yes
standard operating procedure
sir
I appreciate the Old Republic symbol
[Music]
or you go with wings there shut the
power down
your Jedi protocol I suppose that's true
it's true
[Music]
good news attention here how does the
ring work in conjunction with the Pergo
that they'd like force it to go through
that of specific ringers yeah or maybe
there's something about this planet
being like the per girls home that you
think this planet is specifically their
home or they just like camped out here
right it's interesting that they're like
in the lower atmosphere of the planet
haven't seen those creatures since the
day Esra disappeared
there are six hyperdrive engines in
place with the final one being set into
position okay but I have never seen one
built on this scale before Intergalactic
travel you can't get a ring like that
make a jump to a neighboring Galaxy
archive speak of Intergalactic
hyperspace Lanes between galaxies which
used to follow the migration Paths of
star whales named perkel oh there we go
like the ones we just saw yeah really
wait a minute
you never believe such a healthy amount
of exposition ah
hunt them down
oh boy
he's so good I can't wait for him in
Ahsoka to fight
not even just standing there he just has
tons it's just such a good villain
oh man I was really enjoying that yeah
ah too short that was way too short too
short but definitely leaves you wanting
more yeah in a good way yeah oh we're on
the right track chit chat I mean it's
pretty obvious that they're setting up
Jason for a future spin-off show or he's
Gonna Wanna become a Jedi guys that's my
big takeaway out of everything happened
in this episode I got one take away yeah
setting up the New Canaan show
[Laughter]
and they can make their own like Young
Avengers get grogu yellow Jason come on
you know they're gonna do more children
well you know he could end up at the
Jedi Temple and you know everything goes
right what happens this is what happens
that's what happens
uh the history repeats that'd be great
maybe get a fun side of Kyla yeah I the
more kylo friend Kyla friend it would be
fun to
depending on how this pans out to have a
large group of characters end up in this
other Galaxy permanently
as to explain their absence in the
sequel Trilogy yeah because I that's
gonna bug me yeah forever big time the
only issue is the ghost
uh Hera's ship is in the sequel Trilogy
yeah it's at the Battle of Mexico
um I overall really like this episode a
lot uh I had a lot of fun with this one
and it was it felt it had that actual
that's spirit that that genuine spirit
and wonder of what I thought Mandalorian
season three was often kind of like fail
at and feel rushed during yeah this
didn't do that yes it's a short episode
uh but still I felt the substance of it
and I I genuinely had a really good time
am I like on the edge of my seed in
terms of like suspense no but in terms
of absorbing the adventure I really feel
the absorption of that and I'm I'm
really finding myself much more endeared
now because the last the last two you
know had a more serious tone which is
not a problem to me at all like I I
overall I loved it uh while I had a
little bit of gripes in terms of
so and I know some people have a push
back on this I feel like there's a
divide here I've noticed some people
have echoed our opinions of some of that
stoism that I was like I could use a
little bit just more pep in the
personality in some way and and I
thought this really brought it with with
Ahsoka and Sabine and the chemistry like
I really felt the chemistry between them
this time yeah and I found myself really
um enjoying the whole training segments
with them especially at the very top of
this episode and then watching as Ahsoka
again being the the master learning from
your Padawan similar to like how like
you know Ahsoka was paired up with
Anakin so Anakin could learn something
about himself as well and now you're
watching that trajectory
um unfold and
while like that's part of the package
usually with Master battle one it this
really feels like okay specifically with
Anakin to Ahsoka and now for Ahsoka to
Sabine it is so is just as much about
the master learning about themselves and
how to be uh as well as the Padawan on
top of that too so I really I really
like this one a lot I like the future of
where it's headed towards and when they
finally reveal that that was Ezra under
the mask the whole time
it's nice to see Ahsoka because I I was
doing a lot of thing about it
um you know and I think everybody in the
comments section agreed like Silk is
like a very
uptight but not the traditional friendly
happy vibrant Ahsoka that we knew in in
the early seasons of The Clone Wars and
you know you can only imagine the trauma
that it is of having somebody that
you're so close with that you know on
such a personal deep intimate level only
for them to fall the way that Anakin did
and I think something that we're going
to continue to explore
is between the relationship between
Ahsoka and Sabine part of the reason
that Ahsoka is struggling to be a real
master is because
that level of being vulnerable
is something that I I think she's scared
to get hurt again and it's not that she
doesn't care about Sabine it's just that
it's you know what if I do this wrong
and and yeah you know my Padawan goes to
the dark side well then yeah the last
time between Rebels to Mandalorian the
last time we saw Ahsoka uh in the
animated format other than the ending
T's the Cliffhanger was that she just
got the revelation of Anakin as Darth
Vader yeah and you can only imagine the
uh emotional trauma and put through
space and time missed several years of
her life some trauma it makes sense to
me I think some people misunderstand if
I say like I don't think stoic is is
necessarily bad yeah and I think that
there is
there's kind of like a multi-layer that
I was sort of craving I guess is what
more because I'm like no it makes sense
to me that she would be different yeah
based off of what she went through like
of course she would be different and
we're starting to see those the
dimensions of the relationship yeah and
the Nuance of it and I really appreciate
what you said about that because I think
we're we're gonna continue to see that
evolution
I'm glad that Hera and I can't believe
I'm saying this isn't coming along for
this leg of the journey if only to give
those to the room for their relationship
to really having just them if only for
an episode or two is really really
important to that relationship
developing in a big way
um I did want to say that uh I felt like
Hera's portrayal
um number one I think uh on an acting
level doing an amazing job I just
remember her being so much better at
politics though like that was something
that was uh when we see her Evolution as
like the leader of you know Phoenix
Squadron and the rebel cell and then the
introduction to the larger Rebel
organization I feel like
she was so good at navigating the nuance
and the politics of it all only to just
like not necessarily be on her game
um and part of me wonders if that you
know is an intentional trying to show
that you know in the absence of of of
Canaan in the absence of you know the
family that she's built
um that she's kind of pulling at strings
for you know what she Longs for and
misses
um but I thought that Dynamic is really
interesting the new Republic I just I I
think they need to do something to make
me care about it
um and they haven't need to do something
to to give the new Republic like a POV
or something more than them just going
it's fine we're the new Republic and
that's it some kind of I think in the
same way that like Mon mothma and Andor
did like such a good job at making the
Rebellion feel more Dynamic and
interesting I'm not saying like I want
like a political thriller but I want to
show that not every single person in the
new republic government is an absolute
idiot right
um because right now it's being set up
is that and it's just it's been
consistently unrewarding uh time and
time again where it's like wow these are
just a bunch of bureaucratic idiots
um which makes everything that was
fought for feel so
that yeah like like what about all the
often spies that died to get them that
information but well yeah I mean I guess
the part of it that lacks a
believability
area because like yeah I get the whole
turn in The Blind Eye thing a history
repeating itself and whatnot is
specifically regarding the Empire like
the fact that they have these former
Empire people as employees and stuff and
they're just like no it's been fun
not a questionable thing about
Allegiance or anything of that regard
just like no no this is just like
one-offs
I think what the new Republic is missing
narratively because like there's a
they're always a drawing from history
and so the historical presidents here is
like yeah we employed an extraordinary
amount of Nazis after World War II
because we were scared of the Soviets I
think the issue is there's like no
they're just like Yeah It's just tough
times you know a lot of Transitions and
things and there's no you know and here
we are creating an existential potential
crisis something that contests the new
Republic something that
um and just instantly they're like ah
yeah we're not gonna take one of our
most trusted generals advice like we're
not gonna
um and like mon Mothman you're the
chancellor like you know I'm sure
they've stripped the powers down
significantly since jar jar but like you
know uh anyway I do want to talk about
The Inquisitor for a minute if that's
okay
um sure because I've been thinking
endlessly about it and while my hope
narratively speaking is that it's still
Barris
I do really really like the idea of Sam
Whitmer who played Maul uh and among
many other characters and also voiced
Starkiller in Force Unleashed I do love
the idea of them bringing a version of
that character to live action and the
reason I love that is because for those
that played forced Unleashed
Starkiller was Vader's apprentice and I
think narratively for Ahsoka who is
Anakin's Apprentice to go head to head
with somebody who was Vader's apprentice
would create such a fascinating Dynamic
definitely
um and if it's Ezra I will lose my mind
because narratively that makes
absolutely no sense it is such a waste
it's weird I feel like it actually does
make sense in terms of if Ezra was
actually with thrawn and was able to see
because you see the problem is this
you're saying thrawn's on the right side
I'm saying
the Nuance that you speak about to
thrawn is present in the books yeah and
stuff that's not present in Rebels yeah
he's very he's very much a bad guy in
rep I think for the most part he's a bad
guy we're in the books let me let me let
me let me out loud yes I think thrawn is
a bad guy who does bad things I think
thrawn became a bad guy who does bad
things Thanos because he's scared of
something yeah stuff like that is a
thousand percent yeah and I think like
the the nuanced complexity where one can
strongly argue that like hey he's not
necessarily just a black and white
villain I feel like there is a way he
can play an influence and especially
with Ezra who has often been teased uh
with the dirtiest the dark side but
alert to the dark side many times I feel
like the dark side can take hold of Ezra
but she also thinks of his friends and
so so he thinks he's doing something
good I I agree on a narrative level that
when we get to the other Galaxy
that we will find in Ezra who may very
well be aligned with thrawn what I don't
think is that that Ezra
somehow managed to travel back to this
galaxy didn't let his friends know
I just I don't I don't see any rational
logical explanation I just explained it
out I do saw the plan I went on the
subway very
I do feel very confident though that
we know
Ezra Bridger that we'd find in this
other Galaxy I think you're absolutely
right in that he'll probably be aligned
with thrawn they'll probably be working
together and that will probably be
really challenging for Sabine who's
probably finally coming into her own
with the force and he's like I'm finally
a Jedi and wait the Jedi admired most in
the world
um is working with the evil villain John
Johnny
yes grand Admiral yawn
that's my name don't wear it out all
right John what did you say the episode
I mean I have so many thoughts about
this very straightforward
action-oriented episode
I mean I liked uh you know I feel like I
said almost just stay on conspiracy yeah
I mean I thought this did a nice job the
the loveliest thing this did was portray
a an action-based situation that the
whole time to me anyway did feel like a
character building and a team building
exercise and I think the ideal you know
it's easy to Dazzle in fact across all
of these shows of debatable quality
we've gone and seen different dog fights
and and recontextualized versions of
other action set pieces we've seen
before and I thought this did nicely
to make something that was visually
gripping and exciting but that also yeah
feels like you are watching two people
mend some aspect of their relationship
or open back up to each other as well as
as you guys pointed out uh learning the
new things one that Padawan needs to
learn from their master and two that
Master needs to learn from the overall
situation and from Padawan in general
and then you got yeah but who's The
Inquisitor it's Ezra Bridger I don't
know no it's not John it's the ghost of
Han Solo
it's not dead yet not dead yet no but
we're gonna get time travel we do
already have time travel oh yeah
Ghost type traveled back and you became
The Inquisitor I was I was pretty
convinced for a minute that Balin was
just an ALT history Anakin Skywalker
from a different parallel universe for a
millisecond I was I feel like the gray
Jedi aspects
of of Balin and and great character
actress
she's honestly so for the fact that we
don't know her name I think she's
extruded I feel like she I feel like
they are representative of
to help set us up for the when we do see
Ezra Bridger that these are these people
are not just like black and white
they're Sith you know that they're not
that we're setting up a way where they
are yes they use dark side stuff but
they really believe they're doing it for
a great cause yeah you know and um I am
wondering why Morgan ellsbeth though
really is
so
uh adamant on serving thrawn that I am
wondering if there's more
because like we're opening up the realm
of magic now yeah I mean it's always
existed but you know there's always been
like this weird subsection where like we
never really explored magic in like the
live action stuff and I'm kind of
wondering if that's going to be the
there's some type of battling of magic
that we're ultimately building to and I
feel like there is
something linked to like that's what's
it in Marvel it's like Wizards aliens
what's the the phrase that they use and
robots and robots that's what we're
that's what they're doing here uh I am
just curious of like what is that planet
that we're ever uh thrawn is on if there
are others is that where the magic comes
from so that's
play into that
my kind of like head Canon Theory at
this point
is they have taken the time now to say
that according to the Jedi there used to
be multiple Intergalactic hyperspace
Intergalactic hyperspace hyperspace
intergalactics
which raises the question
um are there night sisters are there
Jedi of a different type yeah that
exists in these other galaxies and is
there just a much larger narrative at
play than what we've been limited there
are people who it's like zootopia but
everyone has the force and they're just
oh yeah but that's but that's kind of
the interesting so like I mean even
special who everyone has yeah but even
like you know in in talking about like
the chess and the unknown regions which
is still in this galaxy like that's
drawn species you know they have a group
of force sensitive youth who are called
the Skywalker Corps and like they help
navigate through these hyperspace lanes
and the you know the difficulties of the
unknown region using the force and so
but they have no other exposure to the
Jedi right and so I think if we're
exploring other galaxies where the force
still exists we will see other
interpretations of how the force
manifests in different societies yeah
which I think leads perfectly into what
you're saying about like well there'll
be some interesting conversations
between Magic and the force and what
that looks like you know but but
ultimately you'll find out if it's
constructed in a lap uneasy yeah it's
been of course obviously drink your
Force juice boys
I think it's about Africa I think
ultimately what we're we're looking at
though with this uneasy alliance between
Baylin and Morgan and Company thrawn
um Ezra and I think soon Ahsoka and
Sabine
and maybe Luke maybe you know and
then jarin and Company I mean because
the other thing that we have to think
about here is that these this is what
he's it's he said we're taking all these
shows and we're going to turn them into
one big cinematic story which means this
Impressions
George Lucas
Dear George Lucas impression now I just
I just I thought you were doing earlier
Dave filoni is Dave filoni he's kind of
like it's like Dave filoni is a cowboy
hat
it's poetry we gotta end this yeah
anyway
um so that's all I have to say it's
poetry not a novel oh yo did you guys
see that um there
I do have they drop some Star Wars
trailers for some video games that's
amazing yeah yeah during this episode no
I can't wait to never get around
that's all right uh maybe I'll start my
own competitive YouTube channel
start reacting Star Wars Theory
explained
use the mic
that's the mic use the mouse
that's great
um double double meaning
um hey we should uh thank you all for
being here like subscribe and uh John
good work today and also uh we should
shout out some patrons let's do that all
right guys we're improvising this let's
start it off tomorrow
Alexander yes and and safirchi Christian
Neal Ryan Smith Kevin Meek Adrian Tims
oh I'm in a quarter here
real knock Goss
[Music]
differently same Marco tan still Lauren
America horse simply faded
sj-94 Justin Martin Lucy baby Darth
yoda06 yes jay bird call it did Phil J
Smith Jr Jen Smith Melanie
love freaking Blanc you are all invited
to join the Jedi Academy
all you younglings out there yeah I hope
you don't get slayed come to the temple
and be with us good job people do yes
well that's the rest of the shout outs
to just be that
appreciate all of you guys thank you so
much for being here yeah we really love
you I love saying your names you have
great names love you we do
surrounded you or Craig
I got Greg's impressions
I'm still here if I shout
bye everybody